hey guys how's it going so welcome back
to cooking with Justine I'm Justine and
as most of you guys know I'm not a very
good cook but that's okay because that's
what makes it fun I think either way
today we're going to be making something
really special probably not actually
that special but we're gonna make
brownies this is not gonna be just any
brownies I can assure you that this is
gonna be poo emoji brownies first steps
first here on the box we need to heat
the oven
all right 350 next up we need to grease
the bottom of a pan well I didn't eat it
in freaking washing of the pans
that's what freaking rocks pan off
pounds okay here's our pan got the pan
mmm greased pan greased pan greased pan
hollow leg raise a pan
the only way that I know how to grease
the pan is spraying a cooking spray
we're grease grease grease like a pig
when I was in high school they used to
do these things where you would do like
class pranks someone greased a pig and
let it go in the school just thought
about that that's great great story
great story great story nobody cares
homie needs a bowl got a bull I just
want to look okay I hear cops please
don't be coming for me that is sharp as
hell oh my goodness that slice through
there can you imagine if that what I'm
cutting all right and we go from brownie
mix desserts cup vegetable oil all right
you know I'm not about measuring here
but um the Third's is about like right
there
all right put you in there 1/4 cup of
water I just want to look okay booyah
okay so yeah to Hawaii boats when do you
experience one Hawaii voz
shoot that was not good
we have huevos everywhere oh holy who I
bows alright let's just freakin get out
of my white oil I think I might need a
better shot of you so what happens when
you shoot a cooking show by yourself
come here you little hole huevos shy
should I blend it we've decided it's
time to blend made a decision all gone
should have done as early on never
questioned myself when I think it's time
to blend something it's always time for
one
all right I hope this works
hmm looks like Pele looks like - oh you
guys see I've got chocolate on me I got
chocolate in my hair and chocolate in my
hair I have chocolate in my hair such a
day ago
all right
carrying on alright so now we're gonna
put this in the oven
I guess 24 to 26 minutes uh ain't got
that kind of time
holy moly okay alright we'll see you in
24 minutes okay
uh I don't know how many minutes it has
been but I don't think time is not tons
not now and I don't know what a brownie
looks like well yeah I do know clearly I
know what a freaking brownie looks like
like homie looks done look at this right
okay that's not done this is this is not
that at all
this here means I am NOT ready to come
and get it no no I'm gonna go with it's
done I still don't have any mittens Oh
God Hot Diggity Dog you're hot as heck
well what do you think do you think it's
done I'm going to let this cool off a
little bit and then we're gonna do some
decorating take a look at this this
looks like actual crap this works like I
just want to flip it and
yay oh my god if I cut myself to I'll
try and make it to emoji okay all right
we're getting somewhere
I wonder how it tastes somebody call
9-1-1 shorty pick some brownie that
tastes good whoa oh my god this looks
like actual turd
supposed to have like tips to put on
here but I don't have that so how are
you supposed to open these tell me cuz I
have absolutely no idea this looks more
like a brownie from Kings than emoji
Pooh there I say you look like thank you
guys so much for watching I hope you
enjoyed this Pooh tastic brownie make
sure you guys like this video if you
enjoy the cooking videos and let me know
in the comments below what you guys
would like me to cook next also don't
forget to subscribe so you'll know when
I post a new video and yeah that's it
for flipping with Justine see you guys
in the next episode one system know if
I'll ever get a boyfriend again
uh-huh yes one did I'm sure I will